it's that time of year again the time
when my favorite shows are preempted by
a holiday-themed programming oh I tell
you the only thing worse than the old
chestnuts are the new chestnuts why do
the North Pole of course the Santa Claus
oh you mean the guy that fell off my
roof oh I'd like to roast them all on an
open fire where are the true Christmas
time classics where are the shame black
movies you know Shane Black the genius
who scripted violent classics lethal
weapon yeah you wanna see crazy I'll
kill the last boy scout what is this and
the long kiss goodnight and they went on
to direct the violent classics kiss kiss
bang bang and iron man 3 now black set
all of these films during the holidays
but not because he's trying to impart a
holly jolly vibe to all the bloodshed
his holiday message is ba mother from
bug Oh mother oh and you can shove that
dreidel right up here until it comes out
of your mouth
it's time to acknowledge the true savior
of the season the guy who makes so many
family gatherings slightly more bearable
when Grandma turns on the TV and cranks
up the volume so I'm gonna go ahead and
start my own holiday Shane blackness
Shane blackness will be a day when we
can watch all of the maestro's films and
celebrate all of the timeless life
lessons found therein ok ok it's true
that the single greatest Christmas movie
of all time diehard duh he became mother
wasn't written or directed by black but
Joel Silver totally stole the idea of
setting it at Christmas time from blacks
Lethal Weapon script I'd say that's
proof of his divinity blessed RV Shane
Black Lord and Savior of Hollywood
deliver us from boredom and protect us
from michael bay so if you start to feel
like someone is pointing a shotgun at
your head and forcing you to sing
treacly holiday music just like in the
long kiss goodnight
then join me in decking the halls with
profane banter Mary Mother shame
blackness to all and to all a good night
what holiday movies do you despise let
me know in the comments